alors à propos de sartre on etienne
barilier n'avait pas cédé à la mode que
dénonce bien henri lévy en faisant un
travail d'ailleurs tout à fait
intéressant et intelligent sur sartre et
aaron non pas en les amalgamant bien
entendu mais toute façon quand même en
les rapprochant non parce que j'insiste
d'autre part sur leur différend sur leur
opposition même total sur un certain
nombre de points jeudi effectivement que
un certain niveau on en certains lieux
de la pensée ils se retrouvent mais je
crois qu alors ne nous retrouverons
aussi en ce lieu là c'est justement le
dieu de la pensée subjective de la
subjectivité préserver contre une pensée
positiviste mécaniste qui supprimerait
la l'homme disent on va penser de
l'homme mais enfin les différences je
les marque enfin l'essentiel du livre
est quand même là pour marquer vous êtes
partir de cette idée qui est bien c'est
que l'un est un artiste et l'autre ne
l'est pas voilà oui je pense qu'en fait
les différences qu'on a cru marquer
qu'on a marqué pendant des années entre
leurs très rares on n'était pas les
bonnes c'est à dire ce n'est pas
vraiment sur le terrain de la politique
que ça se passe bien sûr ça apparemment
été marxisant aaron apparemment vraiment
apparemment était plutôt à droite mais
en fait le débat est tout à fait
différent je crois car on a reproché
deux choses à ça il lui a reproché
certaines choses qu'il reprochait à
d'autres vins intellectuelle il a
attaqué sarthe en tant qu'intellectuel
et beaucoup plus il lui a reproché
certains manquements je dirais
d'artistes qui mélange les genres
c'est surtout ça la question lui
reprochent surtout lui qui émeut d'airé
aaron lui reproche sa violence oui et
vous mais justement cette violence se
trouve être en quelque sorte la
transposition de la philosophie
sartrienne ou disons de la vision du
monde sartrienne tel quel dans l'univers
du politique et cette transposition est
ensuite rationaliser à outrance par
sartre de telle façon que ça pressait de
nous persuader que la raison même voeu
que la violence soit
soit la maîtresse du monde en quelque
sorte d'en face on a le sens de
l'évolution humaine et orbi notre
passage sur la boxe et le tennis
pourquoi ça faisait de la boxe moi je
suis même pas sûr que c'est votre titre
parce que de même que dans son livre
bernard henry se trouve qu'ils ont
abusif que au musée d'orsay
on est les pompiers et les
impressionnistes sur un plan d'égalité
moi je veux dire que sartre et aaron tu
vas l'immense écrivain da noz et dayraut
strates vraiment un écrivain dont le qui
restera dans l'étape française dans les
siècles des siècles
et puis un homme qui était pour moi à
mes yeux ça quand j'étais quelqu'un de
très important pour les lecteurs du
figaro pour les gens qui font sciences
po souvient mon frère aîné qui faisait
six ans pour en parler avait beaucoup de
considération
bon c'est très bien mais j'avais jamais
même compris coupons pu les comparer
lorsqu'il a écouté arbre lui si j'enlève
dernières années d'art ont d'ailleurs
qu'il a cru que cette formation lui même
et du canard et s'active tiennent la
rivière et part en lui même ne voulait
pas qu'on les compare à mais enfin
écoutez je ne sais que le dire je ne
vous ai pas rencontrés mais en tout cas
si j'en juge par ses textes il se met
toujours en second rang derrière sartre
mais c'est je considère je considère
qu'il y a deux génies qui sont peut-être
des gal valeur de génie créateur qui est
celui de sartre et que j'admire
infiniment et le génie de la
compréhension je dirais je trouve et qui
suppose à la fois des qualités
intellectuelles immense et des qualités
morales immense et ce génie ar on
l'avait et je trouve admirable vraiment
admirable qu'un homme comme aaron et pu
rester l'ami de sartre et je veux dire
et le comprendre profondément elle
comprendre mieux que beaucoup de sartre
et roger pathétique et roger grenier
je disais mode je suis pas d'accord
parce que j'entends encore aaron
m'expliquer comment il avait il avait
expliqué à sartre comment il fallait
faire pour être reçus à l'agrégation
bon alors oui non moi j'aime beaucoup de
l'udps etienne barillier parce que il
entre il entre dans les oeuvres enfin il
échoue
ne sacrifie pas tellement l'anecdote et
et nous parle de la critique de la
raison dialectique ou 9e les
intellectuels oui mais aussi les
anecdotes qui font envie
bien sûr ma place c'est ma philosophie
est important de gens mais ce que je
crois parce que ça touche tous les gens
dont nous allons parler ce soir c'est
que il ya l'homme et puis il ya l'oeuvre
sartre par exemple était quelqu'un de
très gentil de très serviable et quand
il écrivait pouvait être injuste
violents injurieux
camus qui avait beaucoup de charme de
rayonnement tout le monde tout le monde
le dit pouvait parfois quand il écrivait
être un peu guindée raymond aron qui le
plus souvent avait raison et qui était
encore plus brillants quand il parlait
que quand il écrivait rebuter en même
temps par son autosatisfaction et puis
c'est justement le l'espèce d'autorité
qui prenait les gens riches au maquis
raison bon quand tu as ces lignes je
crois que j'aime bien de l'avoir connu
oui alors j'en reviens aaron et sape les
distinctions sont très sont très
pertinentes vous faites est monté par
exemple que même si un peu exagéré que
sartre celle imaginaire puisque c'est
l'artiste et que aaron 8 c'est le réel
c'est une philosophe qui parle des
choses du moment mais il semble que
celui que celui qui s'occupe de
l'imaginaire et plus d'influencé sur le
réel que l'autre c'est le grand problème
c'est la grande responsabilité je dirais
encore plus des artistes écrivains que
des intellectuels c'est là qu'on peut
faire une différence c'est que pour
l'artiste il y a encore la force du bo
dix ans le tout simplement de
l'esthétique au sens le plus noble du
terme qui jouent et en artiste construit
une oeuvre dans la fiction dans
l'imaginaire mais qui précisément a un
poids énorme sur le réel
est ce qu'on peut reprocher me
semble-t-il en dernier ressort un sartre
est peut-être la seule chose qu'on
puisse lui reprocher c'est de n'avoir
pas donné aux lecteurs les moyens de se
rendre compte qu'ils disent est de la
fiction je dirais 7,7 fait prendre au
mot dans ses textes dans cette ex
polémique même dans ses textes
philosophie lorsqu'on y regarde vraiment
de très près on s'aperçoit qu'au fond il
s'agit de fiction et à ce moment là le
lecteur peut reprendre ses distances et
bénéficier dirait de la beauté de
l'oeuvre sans prendre tout cela pour
argent comptant
mais on ne se rend pas compte sarc nous
donnent pas toujours les moyens de nous
en rendre compte
et curieusement aussi vous montrer que
si l'un prend marx au sérieux ce n'est
pas ça comme on pourrait le croire mais
c'est aaron oui ça c'est tout à fait car
à klasnic mans certains prétendent les
mauvaises langues disent que sartre
naguère du marx bon peut-être va-t-il
lui mais en tout cas art on la lui
davantage là beaucoup pratiqué elle
respecte infiniment encore ce génie de
la compréhension il ya des textes
admirable de compréhension et d'humilité
je dirais quand même
daron sur marx est d'ailleurs rare on
voulait écrire un grand essai sur marx
il est mort trop tôt
mais de son côté sartre fait du sartre
tout le temps c'est son génie en effet
sa puissance il avale marx comme il
avale tout le monde et il emploie alors
on essaie une langue de bois marxiste
surtout d'un crédit que le réseau
électrique mais si on y regarde de près
c'est un écrivain qui emploie la langue
de bois en disant regardez comme je
l'emploie bien il ya toujours création
d'une distance mais plus ou moins
visibles et le drame c'est qu'elle n'est
pas toujours très vives
j'ai trouvé votre lit